brown's fans were sweating out the
question of whether or not they would be
adding janaevian clowney the number one
overall pick in the 2014 draft played
with the texans played with the seahawks
played with the titans
he's clearly in the one year at a time
phase of his career
i feel badly for the guy he never got
the gigantic payday that his talents
would have justified because of the
rookie wage scale
that said he gets a one-year deal worth
up to
10 million with the browns that means
what he's actually getting is less than
that he's gonna have to do some things
do some stuff
and you never know what stuff he's got
to do until you see the details he may
have to be the super bowl mvp
to get the full 10 million we don't know
either way what we do know is
he is a member of the browns sharing
your first reaction
when you saw that he's going to be
across from
and or to the left of working from the
inside
of aggie great miles garrett
well i just remember last year mike when
jadavian clowney signed with the titans
we all thought it was such a big deal
how much it was going to help the titans
defense and of course
jadavan clowning does what he has done
many seasons in his career he got hurt
he didn't have any sacks last season for
the titans and guess what they were last
in the nfl and sacks 19 total sacks last
year so
while the hype train's going while it
looks like it's a really good
signing you know we'll have to see how
long can he stay on the field how much
damage can he cause but i do
think it's a great signing from the
browns from the standpoint of they have
the money they have the cap space
and they have miles garrett there to to
help jadaveon clowney he was at his best
when he had
jj watt and i know jj watt was hurt a
couple of those years but there was one
year there when they were both
really really good and i think you could
have that again in cleveland with those
two guys rushing the passer
so they had all of that mike and they're
on the verge i think of doing
something really big in cleveland so
having him help them
take that next step i think it was a
good signing i'm not going to get all
hyped about it and say they're going to
the super bowl but
because they signed avion clowney but i
do think it was a good signing
the reality with davey and clowney is
that when he is fully healthy he is
capable of being
one of the most disruptive players in
the national football league
on the defensive side of the ball
regardless of what his stats show
what he does and this is a statistic
that we are still trying to get the
elias sports bureau to officially
recognize the chris sims f up the play
stat
where one guy just by virtue of how he
explodes or implodes the offensive line
destroys whatever it is that the offense
is trying to do
and i thought one of his finest moments
sharing was on a monday night in the
2019 season when he was playing for
the seahawks against the 49ers he was a
one-man wrecking crew the problem is by
the end of the game
he could feel a sports hernia coming on
and he was affected by it
the rest of the game so if he's healthy
he's awesome the problem is
he has had a chronic injury history and
that just
is what it is and some guys just get
injured more than others some guys put
so much into everything that they do
they play with such reckless abandon
they set themselves up to get injured
and we were on the
text chain the pft writer text chain
today and you know i said hey it's
almost like a comet
you see it briefly and brilliantly and
then it's gone for two or three years
and it's going to come around again at
some point for the browns this year the
problem is how long is it going to last
it's not going to last 17 games and
they can just hope the genavian clowney
is close to 100 percent
when the games matter most in january
assuming the browns get back
i will add motivated to that when
healthy when healthy and when motivated
he can be one of the best players in the
nfl and he and
you know he talks about defensive player
of the year he's never even been all pro
he's been
pro bowler three times he's never had
double digit sacks and a lot of that
is because of the injuries when he's
motivated and he's healthy we saw in
that 49ers game you talked about that he
had a sack a forced fumble fumble
recovery resulted in a touchdown
he was dominant in that game and we saw
it earlier that season with the seahawks
against arizona he also scored a
touchdown in that game had two sacks
you saw it in flashes with the texans
there was one game against the colts
when he just destroyed the colts
when he was playing for the texas so
you've seen it in flashes you've seen it
in spurts you know what he can do
we just want to see more of it mike we
want to see it for a full season we want
to see it for eight games or 10 games or
12 games
even if it's not 17 games this season we
need to see it more than what we've seen
it from
davion clowning in his career manage the
reps in games
manage the practice time be smart with
jadabi and clowny keep him healthy and
you're right keep him motivated
as often as possible we talked about
what motivated him to choose the
cleveland browns last year they wanted
him
he opted not to play for the browns this
year he did here he is from earlier
today talked to reporters about why
he landed in cleveland uh jadavian can
you just talk a little bit about
uh why were you so excited to come to
the browns this year
when i know they pursued you very hard
last year and
uh i heard that their offer was higher
than anyone else's so why this year why
not last year
uh uh circumstance changed and i got a
new
um i got a new agent and
he was more open uh about just about
coming here and
wanted me to take a visit my last one i
didn't tell me to take no visit but
this one made me visit and i came and
visited i got to sit down with the staff
and got to know some of the guys and it
made me
made it much more easier for me to come
here and play
again i firmly believe jamie clowney is
in that one year at a time phase of his
career
and even if he has a big year somewhere
i know that a team may be
tempted to do a multi-year contract it
just has never shown to be something
that
is sustainable but it's that lure of
what he can be
it's that hope of what the browns could
be
and if he is healthy he will make the
browns better we just don't know that
that'll happen i talked earlier about
putting today van cloning on the same
defensive line with miles garrett
clowney address that as well earlier
today shireen here he is
curious
a lot has been made about you pairing up
obviously with miles garrett and that
your arrival will help him how much will
playing with him help you
a lot i've been getting double team off
a lot in this league
my career and i'm looking forward to
playing with somebody
dominant on the opposite side like a
mouse gear who can
draw a double team maybe i can go
one-on-one more
and that really is the key you know a
dominant defensive player gets double
team sometimes triple teamed
there's only so much attention you can
give to davey and clowney
if you're worried about miles garrett
shireen and i think that
is all the reason for clowney to be
attracted to cleveland go to a team
where there already is that dominant
defensive player so you get more
favorable matchups more opportunities
to create havoc more opportunities to
get more sacks something he hasn't had
nearly as many of
as the talent would suggest yeah you
look at what
olivier vernon did last year and he's a
free agent he had 14
starts for the browns last year opposite
miles garrett he had nine sacks he had a
great year and and so if jadav and
clowning can play 12-14 games for the
browns he can get
back in that nine and maybe even have
ten sacks his first double-digit sax
season
with miles garrett opposite him
obviously teams put a lot of their focus
on stopping miles garrett right he was
having a defensive player of the year
kind of year two years ago when he had
the suspension and then last year he
comes back and has 12 sacks in 14 games
so he's been dominant and they also
signed tech mckinley who i think
if they can get his career going again
he can be a rotational player and come
in and spell those two
guys they could have a pretty darn good
pass rush in cleveland mike
tack mckinley was a first round pick of
the falcons back in 2017. adding clowney
gives the browns 10 first-round picks
three number one overall picks and one
super bowl mvp do you know who the super
bowl mvp is who's on the ground sharing
i do malcolm smith that's right he was a
seventh round pick 10 years ago by
the seattle seahawks right place right
time as part of a dominant seahawks
performance where they had to make
someone the mvp
i i don't know did you vote on that one
i think he just could have thrown a dart
at five different guys
for the mvp of that game yeah i think i
did vote for malcolm smith in that one i
keep most of those things i just like
having them and
going back and seeing who i voted for
i'm pretty sure i did vote for malcolm
smith in that one
i keep all mine too never had one so
i never lose them hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports